Well,
hello, how are you? Greetings to him and
Jaramillo with his brief information for
today, Monday, July 26, a new report
by 67 shows the
grades of the students
during the second two months, about
half of the students attending
high school received at least
while high school students were
around 40% and elementary students
31%, these grades are
alarming. However, parents can
help improve this, since they can
contact teachers directly if they believe that
their son or daughter  they are not doing well your
child may need private assistance
there is a back to school event today
inside the
cargáis rec center is located on mcquaid near
tropicana starts at 9am
and ends at noon students
can get backpacks school supplies
exams  of view and much more and for
those who like soccer there
are already the semifinalists for the
gold
cup that  atar will face the united states on
thursday starting at 4:30 local time as
well as mexico against canada
starting at 7pm also
on thursday in las vegas we can't wait
to find out who will qualify
as the grand final is  he will play inside
the rangers home stadium at bid
on the first of august and now we move
on to his weather forecast
a day with high humidity and clouds is expected a
high around 93 degrees as
well as an 80 percent chance
of  rain and storms have a good
day I am salí jaramillo and this was his
brief information for them now in
Spanish
[Music]